gut versteckt unter fast vier kilometer
dicken eisschichten hat ein schottisches
forschungsteam jetzt eine unglaubliche
entdeckung gemacht 91 vulkane wovon der
grösste knapp 4000 meter hoch ist noch
nicht klar ob sie derzeit aktiv sind
oder wie hoch das risiko ist für ihn
nahe zukunft aktiv werden
fest steht aber eine eruption könnte
verheerende folgen für die ganze
menschheit haben wie die vulkane genau
entdeckt worden sind was man bisher
über sie weit und welche gefahr von
ihnen ausgeht jetzt im blick zum zweiten
wechsel herzlich willkommen mit dem
vulkan kilimandscharo london ag und
vielen anderen aktiven vulkan galt
bislang ostafrika als die region der
erde mit der größte vulkandichte doch
diesen rang können sie ihnen eine
bestimmte region in der antarktis jetzt
ablaufen konkret geht es um das
sogenannte west antarktis system ist
verläuft etwa 3500 kilometer vom an
aktiv ross schelfeis bis zur
antarktischen halbinsel des gilt
tatsächlich als eines der am wenigsten
untersuchten gebiete der erde schon vor
knapp 20 jahren war dort ein vulkan
entdeckt worden
der wohl vor etwa 2300 jahren
ausgebrochen sein muss geologisch man
dem anschlag ein team der engelbert
university suchte auch von dessen nach
weiteren spuren die auf vulkane
hinweisen könnten
typisch geformten körper sind
tatsächlich aus der luft zu erkennen es
halt sie aus dem eis heraus fragen oft
halten sich jedoch unter einer kilometer
dicken eisschicht versteckt deswegen
helfen sich die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler anders und analysierten
vorherige studien in denen raba signale
protokolliert worden waren
denn diese sind in der lage die dicke
eisdecke zu durchdringen und können so
hinweise auf mögliche basaltfelsen
geben bereit gestein entsteht kurz
zusammengefasst wenn magma an der
erdoberfläche erkaltet und sich an
bäume steine oder mineralien dabei
anschließen ihre ergebnisse werteten
sie dann in hinblick auf weitere
satelliten daten aus anderen studien aus
und wie waren selbst total überrascht
von dem ergebnis dass vier kilometer
dicke verdeckt 138 vulkane 91 davon
waren bislang noch unbekannt der
kleinste von ihnen mit ein
der größte sind etwa so groß wie der
schweizerische aigner also knapp 4000
meter hoch und die nun 138 bekannten
vulkane dort werden wohl nicht die
einzigen sein die eisdecke wird
höchstwahrscheinlich noch mehr
vulkankegel verstecken so die ansicht
des forschungsteams ihre entdeckung ist
wirklich sehr spannend und faszinierend
auch ein bisschen beängstigend wie
könnte zeigen wie sich der kontinent
während zurückliegender klimatischer
wechsel verändert hat zudem könnten
die vulkane hinweise darauf geben
welchen einfluss sie auf die eisdecke
und damit auch auf den meeresspiegel
haben bislang kann das forschungsteam
noch nicht abschätzen ob die neu
entdeckten vulkane derzeit aktiv sind
doch dies ist tatsächlich eine info die
ist schnellstmöglich herauszufinden
gilt wenn die aktivität der vulkane
könnte verheerende auswirkungen haben
die eisdecke könnte instabil werden und
dies hätte weitere unabsehbare
konsequenzen sollte es zu einer eruption
kommt wäre diese nicht unbedingt an der
oberfläche der als decke erkennbar
allerdings würde das als direkt über
dem vulkan im erheblichen umfang
schmelzen was zu einem anstieg des
meeresspiegels führen könnte so das
forschungsergebnis außerdem könnte die
eisdecke deutlich stabilisiert werden
diese vorstellung macht die geologen
tatsächlich etwas mit ihrer theorie
falls die einzige abnimmt könnte dies
wiederum eine erhöhte vulkanische
aktivität zur folge haben denn ohne die
eisdecke könnte der druck in der region
nachlassen und die vulkane aktiv werden
lassen
das worst case szenario wäre dann eine
kettenreaktion die zusätzlich zu dem
durch den klimawandel ausgelösten
anstieg des meeresspiegels einen
weiteren anstieg verursachen würde
eine absolute katastrophe hierbei klicks
um halte ich euch natürlich auf dem
laufenden was die forscher noch
herausfinden werden wenn ihr kein video
zum thema und auch zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann sollten wir
hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst
nicht den genau auf die glocke hier geht
es weiter mit der südpol zerbricht da
geht es um die dramatischen
veränderungen in der arktis liga
aktuell passiert sind sehr sehr
interessant also nicht packen und
braucht klicken und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt